so thanks for that introduction I
totally don't remember that happening at
all but it is probably a good sign for
any of you students out there you should
cold call and cold email people my inbox
has gotten out of control so at this
point I say if you cold email me give it
a couple days and then do it again and
keep that cycle up until I eventually
get beaten down and respond to you
because they do want to respond to these
kinds of things but yeah inbox problem
for those of you who are interested in
my rantings about the beautiful weather
in California or politics Jillian are
Hayes's your Twitter handle if you are
interested in learning more about autism
technology more broadly autism tech is
your handle for me from a Twitter
standpoint I apologize I normally try to
post accessible versions of my slides
and I just completely forgot that
sabbatical brain for you so if anyone
needs accessible versions of the slides
please don't be shy in emailing me and I
will be happy to get those to you and I
believe they're recording the talk as
well so I can also get those to
whoever's recording if that's helpful
okay so here's my career an aside as
Michael said my backgrounds in computer
science I started out at Vanderbilt in
Nashville Tennessee but otherwise
similar to Stanford in a lot of ways
proper computer scientist I actually
thought I wanted to do theory I had a
double major in math and I loved doing
proofs but I wasn't quite ready for grad
school so I went first to Deloitte and
then to a Vinod where I discovered the
people actually interact with your
computing systems and I thought that was
pretty cool and so I went back to grad
school at Georgia Tech where I started
out doing lightweight note-taking and
then quickly discovered that some of the
most interesting sort of issues with
note-taking actually involved chronic
conditions and in particular I started
doing work in autism my advisor Gregory
a bud who many of you have probably
either met or read has two kids with
autism so that's what got me interested
in that space and I've continued that
work now for for quite some time um
after I got my proper faculty job at
Irvine I decided I needed to go back and
refresh my skills a little bit this is a
common
thread it in my career of going back and
forth academia industry back and forth
so went and worked at an agency round
arts which is now round art isobar for a
little while so if any of you are
thinking about agency life or consulting
life I'm happy to talk to you later this
afternoon about what that's like and
then I've been at Irvine for 10 years
and as Michael said I'm on sabbatical at
the moment can't you tell I'm absolutely
terrible
it's about achill I continue to spend
way too much time on campus and other
things but the two primary things that
I'm working on while I'm on sabbatical
are these two startup companies so a
company called a VA that focuses on
private aviation and a company called a
SharePoint which I'm going to talk to
you about a little bit more today which
is focused on insurance and that will
all become more clear soon enough I
promise ok so personalization most of
the time when we think about
personalization this is the kind of
stuff we're thinking about we're
thinking about how we each have our
identity deeply enriched and then mapped
in our Starbucks cups or your Pete's cup
or whatever your preference might be
increasingly manufacturing has become so
cheap that we're having all of these
sort of personalized gifts this is this
kind of thing is what gets sent to the
family back east
every December in my house Holden is
probably a similar kind of experience
for many of you we have things like
Netflix of course that you're you all
are very familiar with at last count
Netflix had around a hundred thousands
on resisted in their database which is
about as micro as I think you can get
when you think about the kind of
personalized selection processes we
might be doing with our movies but
basically what I want to say is that
personalization it's no longer about
customizing our preferences and
shouldn't be you know it's not even just
about learning what content we might
want to consume or really micro
segmenting that in the way that Facebook
and Twitter and Netflix and these other
kinds of companies do but in fact we now
are in a place where a combination is
sort of new kinds of platforms and
interaction models and algorithms and
tons and tons and tons of data
means that we don't have to have all
these customization engineers Netflix
has a few hundred of them we're moving
towards the world in which we're not
gonna have those kinds of folks anymore
the algorithms are going to do this this
is the thing that's terrifying people
right so this is sort of your last
picture here is personalization getting
out of control I'm sure no actually if
any of your undergrads you're probably
not watching the news at all because
you're living in a bubble but for those
of you who are not undergrads
you're probably very aware of the fight
over things like fake news Gartner just
predicted that within the next three
years we're going to consume more fake
news than authentic news and I think
that's actually probably a longer time
frame then it's going to take right so
this is the sort of downside of all of
this push towards personalized content
if we feed everyone what they want all
the time there can be challenges but
it's a nice Friday afternoon it's the
Sun is coming out we're not going to
talk about that stuff we're not going to
talk about the dark world of algorithms
instead what I want to talk to you about
is the new platforms for true
personalization so I think most of the
world has unfortunately not necessarily
thought about large groups of people so
as Michael said I think a lot about
underrepresented or vulnerable
populations this started out in my work
with autism and you're still going to
hear about people with autism today
other kinds of accessibility chronic
health concerns and other people who are
left out of the economic market out of
design decisions and so on so beyond
just these sort of AI and algorithmic
possibilities we live in this world in
which our perceptual reality can and
does change and if you're a person whose
perceptual reality looks a little bit
different than someone who's typically
developing if you have a chronic
condition if you have a disability if
you have a nerve neurodevelopmental
difference then this creates a whole
bunch of opportunities where we can
shape reality to be something that is
the most comfortable that is the most
effective for you as I said there's also
other ways in which we're shaping
reality that we're not going to talk
about today
so this is an image I took from deloitte
and modify
a bit but this gives you some idea of at
least what the industry is thinking
about in terms of new platforms for
personalization so we do we look at
things like chat BOTS on the one end
that are moving away from sort of a
point click and type but we're still
using sort of our traditional smartphone
or computer based interfaces I just saw
as I was flying up this morning I got
prompted with a news story about the
wobot which I just like to say cuz it's
cute but you know these kinds of chat
bot interfaces to perform all kinds of
things and the way BOTS for those of you
don't know it is a piece of work from a
psych professor here at Stanford focused
on cognitive behavioral therapy through
chat BOTS and these are kind of the new
kinds of platforms that I think are
really interesting you can have a
therapist who's truly customized to your
needs through these kinds of things
things like touch and swipe and talk and
so on a gesture is that a lot of the PhD
students that I've talked with today are
working on well a lot of futurists are
sort of looking at this they put forth a
really compelling vision for the
spectrum but I will point out that most
of these futurists think that most of
our users look like that guy and so yes
they all look like Michael and so what I
try to do is sort of problematize that
and unpack it I want to support Michael
I do I like him quite a bit but I also
want to support a lot of other people
who are not necessarily represented in
what we're thinking about here and so we
can do that now in really interesting
and exciting ways because we have 3d
printing because we have augmented
reality and virtual reality and these
other things so what I want you to bear
that in mind is that what I try to do is
play with these new platforms to think
about how they can support people who've
traditionally not been well supported by
technology and think about that in a
different way so we'll start with 3d
printing this guy's super excited about
3d printing his name is RC life on and
he loves 3d printers he does reviews of
them on YouTube so if you're ever in the
market for a 3d printer you can check
him out he could he's kind of
entertaining but you know we had this
question about like why is he so excited
what is so exciting about 3d printing
well you can do stuff like this this is
a bobblehead of me that my adviser
Gregory about here made Jen man cough is
the other person in this picture who's
also holding a bobblehead of her her
bobblehead is sitting in a yoga pose
knitting mine is baking a cake because
you can make personalized gifts and
that's pretty cool but god help us if
this is all we're doing with 3d printers
right let's hope that this is not the
end-all be-all of personalization so at
the other end of personalization is
thinking about truly making custom
platforms for people who don't have the
same kind of access and opportunities
that many of the people in this room do
so just some stats for you on blindness
in the US
I'm almost 4 million people have a
serious visual disability so that
usually means they're legally blind they
maybe have some sight but have a very
serious disability and that's between
the ages of 18 and 64 the reason we look
at these numbers is they're economic
indicators so this is typically what's
considered working age also beyond 60
for nearly everyone starts to have some
kind of visual disability at some point
anyway we're all going to have a visual
disability by the way just give it time
you will get there less than half of
this group is employed if you're blind
the likelihood is cognitively otherwise
physically everything else you are
exactly the same as a sort of
typically-developing neurotypical person
but yet less than half of this group is
employed why is that well a lot of it we
believe is because we don't have access
to computational systems in the same way
for people who are blind as for people
who have sight and is deeply inefficient
to use your trip typical sort of office
related products and other kinds of
things that you would use in a workplace
if you're blind it just takes a really
long time eventually we start to have
problems there at the same time the
younger ages are not reading Braille
anymore so this is the way we used to
sort of get around it when you had
paper-based reports and so on everyone
just learned to read Braille almost no
one reads Braille anymore this is
largely because of the advent of screen
readers and other kinds of audio based
technology so all of the ways that you
could sort of be as efficient or
disappearing and so what you do see
occasionally it's very expensive Braille
displays so this is the equivalent of a
computational display but with Braille
you swipe your finger across it they're
outrageously expensive they're hard to
learn they're hard to come by they break
a lot auditory screen readers and so on
and magnification so if you have any
sight at all what you'll typically see
is people magnifying their screens
intensely that's more efficient than a
screen reader but it's still pretty
inefficient if you think about the way
that we interact with with most gooeys
and for those of you haven't seen a
screen reader before I will hopefully
play one for you or not arc-fault wind
mail by goethe folders heading loving
student mark inbox 26 link alt + mark
baldwin mail inbox link search link
images mail table with 36 rows and 4
columns Row 1 column 1 checkbox not
checked out of checkbox column 2 hi
column 3 link link February 20th column
4 February Row 2 column 1 column 2 you a
double column and that was mark using it
and he's a pretty adept screen reader
user and he was clicking through
sometimes before the thing actually was
finished reading it the problems you
have with screen readers are you have
lexical and semantic information thrown
together all into this auditory channel
and the auditory channel is ephemeral
and it's linear and this is just a
really hard way to process a lot of
information so what you see is people
backing up re listening to the same
thing over and over again sometimes
skipping things because they're trying
to go quickly and so on so what we've
been working on is pulling the semantic
information out of the auditory and
putting it into the tangible so we talk
about is reappeared
reading the physical metaphor so you
have this metaphor of a desktop you have
metaphors of file folders and other
kinds of things that were originally
physical interactions that you had in
the office place and we moved those into
a virtual model and that basically made
it really hard for anyone who's not
using visual interaction and so we want
to pull those back out into the physical
world so the two systems that you see
here and this is one of a participant in
a study that we did doing some online
shopping and what's going on here is on
the one hand there's a scroll bar that's
what's on the left side there that bumps
when you hit links and has varying sort
of resistance so it feels like a bigger
or smaller document depending on how big
the web pages and so on and then what's
on the right hand side is a contact
switcher so you grab these little die
and they have Braille characters printed
on the top and you know okay this die is
associated with Amazon and this one's
associated with eBay and this one's
associated with another shopping site so
I can switch between the sites and so on
and this is just showing us with the
screen reader output was going on on the
other side you can't get rid of the
auditory Channel altogether with
tangible we're still gonna have to get
the sort of tax or lexical data out of
the auditory but this allows you to be a
little bit more efficient with things
and what we saw was that especially with
novices who weren't super adept with all
the keyboard shortcuts and other things
you might see with screen readers you
see substantial improvement very quickly
so they can sort of walk up and use this
kind of system in a way that screen
readers take years of practice and
learning to get adept with them that's
the tangible desktop we've been moving
forward from this a little bit and I'll
show you kind of what this translation
looks like so we've got sort of the
abstract representation of the
computational interface on the left
there and what you would see with a
traditional screen reader is it would
read out as you just heard
having level 1 introduction link more
information and so on what we view
instead
provide a little day tent so it
basically feels like you're running your
finger across a ridge that tells you
that it's a header it tells you
introduction and then it reads
introduction and a little vibration that
tells you you've hit a link and that
gives you more information so you get a
sense of kind of how that works and
here's the results I was mentioning so
39 percent improvement for the novice
users improvements for every participant
we did this with sighted users as well
I'm just showing you the blind ones here
sighted users also improved but I just
don't care about them as much as the
blind users and it's not surprising that
sighted users would not know how to use
a screen reader what's interesting about
the blind users of course is they all
were working with their system versus
ours so we didn't have a controlled
screen reader this is their screen
reader and their magnification setup and
everything that they traditionally used
on their own personal computers so
actually their walk up and use of our
system was better than what they were
doing with their systems that they were
using but they'd all only been screen
readers for about six months to a year
so they were part of a training program
learning screen reader use would you
attribute to the decoupling of semantics
and like textual information and how
much would you attribute to essentially
the ability to get a better focus
context view um I think both are true
what we see in the field work so what we
did before we did this is about a year
of fieldwork with the same group and
what we saw is they get lost in the
audio a lot so that's where the
decoupling helps because it's just less
stuff and so they're not hearing as much
audio and then they don't know what the
computers done and so you see a lot of
where people get lost and we actually
didn't address this in this system but
and the next one we're working on it but
you get you get sort of the computer has
done something to be smart to help you
and you've lost that because you can't
see it so autocomplete is a really good
example of this it doesn't the screener
doesn't read it out so you wind up
typing the same word like six times
because you you start typing it and it's
Auto completing it and doing a bunch of
other things that are just
broken in the way that we deal with with
websites for for people with visual
disabilities but I also think the focus
plus context thing is huge and I'm super
glad that you asked because it's a
really good segue into the next thing so
you know we sort of after we had this
early success we stepped back we started
working with our partners at this
employment agency for people with visual
disabilities and said what's this bigger
problem and some of it is this focus
context kind of issue so let's just say
I decided to I'm working on a paper and
I've put it away and I would come back
to it the next day and I want to pull it
up so have this overall activity that I
want to do think about this as writing a
paper well it turns out that writing a
paper actually has all of this other
stuff involved with it
I mean so it has the word processor that
I'm actually writing the paper on we do
pretty well with word processors
actually for visually impaired users but
I also need to look at the literature
and maybe I have multiple papers open
plus you know Mendeley or whatever I'm
using to manage my citations
I want to message with my co-authors
I've got a slot channel open or whatever
the case may be and I'm trying to chat
with people about this paper and so on
so there's a whole bunch of other parts
that are inside this activity and first
sighted users we have lots of ways of
dealing with this one is our smanos are
quite big now we tile things out we
might even move things into a virtual
desktop that we're flipping between
really quickly and we're pretty facile
with that but for a non sighted user
this takes a really long time to
actually just sort of pull the context
back up figure out where you were what
was going on and deal with dealing with
it and so we turned to activity theory
too as a way of thinking about this so
if some of you may have seen
activity-based computing but this idea
that we need to actually organize things
and think about things as a human
activity as opposed to a set of
applications that we might be using
which is a lot of overhead for a sighted
user because we can just so quickly pull
the stuff back in but for someone who
doesn't have cannot be as facile with
things thinking in an activity and
saying I want to restart
that activity that I was working on
remember everything about it actually
becomes really important so what we
think about here is organization by
activity so we've been developing
activity tokens what are wait what are
tangible ways for people to associate I
was working on a paper I was working on
a job application I was doing whatever
with a particular token something
physical that I can grab and say okay
I'm working on that activity now
activity context so being able to pick
up exactly where you left off so you
don't have to have your screen reader
read your entire paper to you until you
get to the point where you want to be
and a lot of websites and even you know
office products now are getting to where
you you pull it up and it says hey
welcome back do you want to start on
side 27 where you last work that works
again pretty well for sighted users
that's not an interaction that works
well yet for the blind community so
those kinds of things that we're looking
at being able to dock and save your
activities and so on
tracking the activities so this is what
I mentioned a little bit in our
fieldwork what we see is people get lost
in what they've been doing where if you
have visual abilities you just look and
you kind of go oh that's what you know
yeah I remember where I was but you have
to reread the whole thing if you are
doing this in a non visual way so we're
working on being able to replay the
interaction history a little bit faster
way that's a combination of audio and
tactile and then finally the
transparency this is the piece where I
was mentioning that the system's doing
things to you and for you that you may
or may not be able to see so again
thinking about what are the contexts and
just helping people sort of orient
themselves within the system so this has
led us to the system that we call kind
which is multimodal and I apologize we
printed it with black plastic which was
stupid because you can't see it but this
has again it incorporates the scroll bar
which can do a whole bunch of things so
it can depending on what mode you're in
and that's what the crank on the side is
doing is it's switching the mode the
scroll bar can be used to switch between
applications to switch between documents
to move within an individual document
depending on the mode that you're in and
then the little chip the little RFID
enabled
that you see mark pulling on the side
that's our activity context so that's
your little nugget that's going to save
everything about that particular
activity that you were working on at any
time and this is meant to work alongside
screen readers we have to develop a
custom screen reader for our use but
eventually you could imagine these kinds
of things being something that you could
cheaply plug in just like you would a
new mouse and it will just automatically
work with the system so that gives you a
sense of where we're at from the
tangible side of things and this a
little bit those of you who are at lunch
so a little bit what we were just
talking about there's this idea of all
of these new kinds of interfaces that
are not our typical screens and not our
typical mobile and wearable devices and
Milgram came up with those virtuality
continuum now quite a long time ago
20-some plus years ago which is
disturbing makes us all feel old but
this idea of you sort of have the most
physical we have our tangibles on the
one side and they just talked to you
about the tangible desktop and kind but
again for our accessibility populations
and other underrepresented groups all
along the spectrum I think it's
important to explore what are the sort
of constraints within these new kinds of
platforms and what are they affording
our our non-typical users as well so
we'll switch over to a are a little bit
and I'll switch to autism and thinking
about autism for a minute okay face to
face communication we all think of this
as something that for most people is
pretty straightforward you learned it
over the period of 10 to 20 years it's
not as straightforward as you think it
is we spend a lot of time working with
children to learn to do face to face
communication but once you become an
adult for most people it's fairly
straightforward and we think about this
a lot you'll hear people talk about kids
with autism is being verbal or nonverbal
and verbal is about what we say this is
the words that are coming out of my
mouth but actually face-to-face
interactions include a ton of nonverbal
stuff and the nonverbal is what we
actually mean and this is a point of
great frustration for people with autism
why don't you just say what you mean
that's really irritating why are you
still talking to me about the weather
when you actually want to talk to me
about something entirely different so if
you take a worldview and you have a kind
of way of communicating that's very
focused on the verb all the nonverbal is
really challenging and this includes our
eye contact so I look around I'm
actually amazed most of you are not on
your computers which is shocking this
looks nothing like an urban presentation
I make eye contact with you guys from
time to time body language right I just
you're probably too much whoever has to
deal with the mic I'm sorry I tend to
wave wildly proximity right it would be
super weird if I started having the talk
like this right so we naturally or have
been instructed to our cultural lenses
every years to do with proximity and
then prosody that's sort of how we say
what we say so all four of these can be
challenging for people with autism to
regulate in a way that the rest of us
understand and interpret correctly but
what we find is that autistic people can
regulate particularly proximity and
prosody those were the two issues that
we looked at because they're really hard
to treat in the clinical literature more
easily with mixed reality support so
when we talk about those each in turn
I'll start with proximity so just show
you guys an example how many of you know
a close talker come on yeah you know
close talkers
it's horrible they're like in your
personal space right and at least in
Western cultures 46 to 120 centimeters
is the appropriate space for we're
having a relatively intimate
conversation but you're not close
talking me you get within 46 centimeters
and it's registers for most people is
uncomfortable I relatively new
acquaintance you should be 121 to 370
centimeters away don't get closer than
that and if you're farther than that I'm
gonna think you don't want to talk to me
which is as important as the being too
close is that I'm not going to engage
you in a social conversation if you're
sitting at a public space distance all
right so we're each sitting at the park
and we don't want to talk to one another
this
an appropriate space and for a lot of
people with autism they have trouble
regulating both the too close and too
far so they may want to engage socially
and are not sort of walking up to the
group and therefore feel excluded
because the group doesn't recognize that
they want to talk to you so we have
these inadvertent miscommunications and
this is just a mismatch right that's
what I always try to say to people this
is not that autistic people are doing
this wrong the rest of us are doing it
right but it's a mismatch
so we're regulating our space in a
slightly different way and that creates
miscommunication so we worked with a
wearable and augmented reality system
that we call procom this is an early
prototype I don't have any pictures of
the newer the newer one without kids in
them so you have to live with this one
but the idea here is that we basically
have scanning so I understand where the
other people are we wanted to have this
be a wearable system so that kids could
take it out into the world and we don't
have to instrument their conversation
partner or a room so is as close to
naturalistic as possible and we sort of
talked to them about where's that where
do we detect other people to be and
where might you want to be if you want
to engage with them socially or where
might you want to be if you don't want
to and and so on and I'm not going to go
into the deep deep deep details of this
except to say green means basically
there's pretty good match between what
they think is going on and what our
proximity metrics would give us yellow
means we're a little bit in a borderline
space and red means there's some sort of
problem either way too far away or way
too close and what you see is in the
baseline trials no tool some of the kids
with autism do just fine which was
surprising because they clinically came
in with their parents and their teachers
complaining but they had trouble with
proximity regulation in in a controlled
study they actually adapted fine which
indicates that we not a proximity
regulation problem so much as that they
don't care they're not paying attention
problem but then we've got other kids
who did struggle and then most of them
with the exception of this little guy
corrected to some degree with use of the
tool again walk up and use kind of
situation not training for those who are
interested this one was just really
excited about the tool and
ran up to our research Confederate and
stood right next to it looks like look
right here you can see us on here which
of course registers is way too close but
was actually a socially appropriate
thing to be doing okay um so it's switch
over to you prosody which is a little
bit harder I have a concept to
understand does anybody ever heard the
word prosody before okay there are some
there are some so basically prosody is
this it's the difference between me
saying hot dog and hot dog all right you
know what those two words are two
phrases mean and then of course the
forever hot diggety dog so a combination
of the actual words that we use and the
way that we say them is what prosody is
and that's what conveys our meaning and
the challenge for our kiddos
particularly in schools and particularly
for young adults trying to get their
first couple of jobs is prosody comes
across or mismatches in prosody for kids
with autism come across as they're being
bored they're tired they're angry
they're sarcastic often none of those
emotions and feelings actually apply but
because of the way that we interpret the
way that people are talking to us we
associate those characteristics with
them and I'll just let you look at this
I won't play the audio for you but the
blue is a teenager without autism and
the yellow is a teenager with autism and
they're having a conversation you can
see across the top they're a little bit
loud at first but then basically the
volume stays relatively stable but the
pitch range is dramatically different
this is a really small pitch range this
is within 25 Hertz
I cannot achieve a pitch range that
small unless I hum that's how small it
is and we you'll see within individual
words
a typical speaker will change pitch
sometimes 200 Hertz within a single word
and so this is what comes across as
bored because they're essentially
relatively monotone to our ears and so
what we wanted to do was create an in
situ
intervention so that instead of
role-playing and practicing and
scripting we could actually give
feedback on the fly so you go into a
social interaction or you go into a job
interview and you get the feedback
immediately on two issues one is volume
so matching volume it's not so much that
people with autism are too loud or too
quiet but that they mismatch with their
conversation partner so if I'm being
loud you should be loud too if I'm being
quiet you should be quiet too and that's
the way we're most happy in a
conversation this doesn evitable mean
that everyone talking to me once of
yelling by the end of the conversation
because I have terrible volume
regulation and then the the pitch mode
so we experimented with a whole bunch of
different kinds of notifications and an
end found that just flashing up flat
whenever there was the monotone voice
detected was easy enough for people to
respond to and we did a couple of
experiments with this one with an in lab
super controlled experiment with four
young adults with autism and the other
with the field study what these are
young adults in a program for teaching
them software testing you've probably
seen in the news there's a bunch of
these programs now it turns out that a
lot of adults with autism not all but a
lot are really good at software testing
and so this is a program focused on on
teaching them to be professional
software testers and we tested with them
with both the volume mode and the pitch
mode and I won't go through all the
details of this except to say that
basically what you see here is volume
works pretty well
pitch basically not at all and why is
this does anyone have any ideas why this
might be yeah yes pictures something
one's less aware of and it's hard to
regulate yeah which is really hard to
regulate um volume is you're not really
aware of it either but it's pretty easy
to regulate alright so I'm a person who
gets louder and louder and louder as a
conversation goes on but if you just say
to me like then I am able to regulate it
I can pull it down alright I can talk at
this level but pitch is much harder and
it creates really contextual so we don't
yet have the tools at least not on
things like
laughs to predict where the conversation
is going so one of the common problems
that you'll see in a conversation
between a typical person and a person
with autism is you'll see that they each
don't know when the other one's done
talking because we tend to end our
sentences in particular ways if we're
done talking and those are different
ways depending on whether I have autism
so that's an example there it also turns
out that upon more research we're
starting to think that this is a
biomarker so there's some which
basically means something you cannot
change and so there's some research
going on the University of Notre Dame
around trying to detect these same kinds
of pitch irregularities in babies to see
if the crying actually looks different
enough that you could use that as a
screener for autism so it may be that
it's not changeable yeah I also in the
lower-left essentially gives you a ratio
variable that is I can sort of I can I
can get feedback as I am just being cool
then what I might under compensate I
might overcompensate I don't know how I
need to go yeah and I do think that's
uncommon you even see that in in
therapeutics settings where what a
common kind of therapy is that you'll
record your video record a conversation
and then play that back and see like
okay listen here and what's fascinating
is that most of the young adults anyway
with autism that we we brought in we do
that kind of work with them they don't
hear it even in the video back whereas
the volume they'll say oh yeah I can see
like I'm being quite loud and so us
giving the feedback if you can't if you
don't even know what we're telling you
is happening it's really hard to then
compensate for that and as I say I can't
make myself trigger it right so I can't
go the other direction either yeah I hit
a couple of questions about that second
graph so like in the no treatment it
goes down anyway like from session 1 to
30 and sundries interpreting that why is
that so probably random chance
but it's not really three sessions it's
nine sessions and they're randomly
distributed so you might get one
treatment and then no treatment and then
a different treatment and then that same
again that makes sense so they're
overlaid as though they're three but
it's actually nine so it could well be
that that's just like the last session
for a lot of people but we don't really
know mostly we don't know is the answer
to what's going on with pitch it's just
a little bit all over the place but none
of these are very good this is 20 at the
bottom here you've got 2015 it doesn't
go all the way down to zero sort of
irregular pitch events in a very short
conversation so if you and I were to
have this you would have zero so those
numbers it's not a great graph ah that
is a great question we don't say it's
going well whose aid getting better so
we don't really know and maybe if we did
longer treatment it would get even
better or maybe this would be as good as
it's gonna get but that it's trending in
the right direction yeah that's a great
question I just struck me that there is
the kind of differences that you see
over here between autistic people and
non-autistic people the same kind of
differences could also show up between
two people from two different countries
yeah our culture's is there literature
in that space that's relevant to this
and or like what's the difference there
in terms of power you might think about
that difference versus this kind of a
difference um there's not a ton of
literature in that space although
increasingly more because distance
collaboration work now that we have such
worldwide distributed teams there's a
lot of people in the work place studies
who are looking at that are we getting
mismatches in our communication because
I'm having a talk with a dev in China
and a designer in Brazil and I'm here
and you know those kinds of issues so
there's more of that coming I would say
the difference is whether or not you can
learn it
right and so that's what we what's why
we're interested in pitch is that it
seems not learn about volume tends to be
very learnable by typical typically
developing people really quickly you
know if you if you go if you get thrown
into a room and which people are really
loud even if you're a basically quiet
person you compensate fairly quickly
most most people do whereas people with
autism won't necessarily unless you tell
them to that make sense okay so moving
along our virtuality continuum the AR
stuff that we were interested in was
really about sort of real-world
experiences so we wanted to get out of
the clinical setting and say what
happens when we're playing on the
playground what happens when we're going
for a job interview and so on and that
all requires colocation in a whole other
stream of my research I'm not going to
talk about today we've been looking at
virtual worlds for kids with autism and
this being a safe fun place to play
because your best friend might be
somebody else with autism who's two two
states over or social skills groups
which tend to be therapeutically driven
but they want people with sort of
similar symptom configurations who are
working on similar kinds of goals to
come together well in Southern
California we have really bad traffic I
don't know if you guys know anything
about that up here and this is really
hard to get five kids with a similar
sort of look to what's going on in
similar goals to a place at four o'clock
in the afternoon to work with a
therapist is wicked on their parents and
on the school's so we started to think
about what could we use virtual reality
as a way to get a similar kind of high
quality in-depth social experience for
these kids but at a distance and we
really didn't know like this is a big
risk I'll give my student Lillian Boyd a
lot of credit for taking this on because
we didn't know if we would even be you
know we don't really know if anybody to
tax things like sound or distance or
whatever in the same way our perception
is quite different in VR than in the
physical world and so we didn't know if
any of this would work
but we replicated the procom work to
some degree so what you see there is
sort of a visualization showing your
personal space bubble and then if you
get to either your two space bubbles are
getting close together so we pop you up
a warning and say you know you might
want to think about how close she really
want to be to this person or this person
you have to get crazy close by the way
to pop up this estep away notification
button there's been lots of for those
who follow the news about what's going
on in VR there's been a lot of sort of
borderline assault cases in VR the
people then claim oh I didn't know that
it was like so uncomfortable to be right
on top of this person in this space so
we don't know is this a perceptual thing
or what but we wanted to look at this
sort of a broad piece and then down here
you have again the volume visualizations
trying to help people understand their
volume in relation to their conversation
partner and then the yellow yellow pink
bar there is turn ticking sort of
similar to Carrie Cara Holly Isis work
visualizing what the balance of a
conversation is this is one of our
kiddos using the VR headsets did this
with about a dozen kids with autism
here's the fun thing totally the
opposite results that we saw in the
augmented reality situation so um what
you see here is proximity regulation
worked pretty well the kids struggled
more with proximity regulation as you
saw in the augmented reality setting but
volume worked not at all and why is this
important well it turns out if you think
about how VR systems are designed we're
very careful about the visual stimulus
and we also presented we did a lot of
work on that visual stimulus volume is
very much mediated by the microphones
and the headphones that you're using so
what would happen is the kids would just
turn their volume down or move the mic
away or do other kinds of things and so
in terms of them actually regulating
their voice they were using the system's
to regulate their voice then rather than
them doing it themselves
which may be just fine if we think about
a sort of prosthetic model then maybe
that's okay and then
I was talking with a friend that
Microsoft Research who works on voices
in games for the Xbox games and he was
suggesting that even with the pitch what
if we could just reproduce the voice
amplified so you take the pitch
variation that is existent and expand it
and reproduce their same voice with an
expanded pitch I have no idea if that
would work or not but there's an
interesting idea of what if we move to a
prosthetic model as opposed to a
rehabilitative model which is what we're
using here but we don't really you know
we're trying to figure out what does all
this mean you know it the kids
definitely understood the feedback they
reported understanding it they weren't
confused by it but proximity definitely
worked much better so we're trying to
kind of figure out what that means over
time okay so remember this back to this
new platforms all this so we've started
out today by talking about a variety of
types of personalization that industry
in particular is interested in and we've
moved from sort of point-and-click
through the 3d printed and tangible into
augmented and virtual reality and so on
but I want to pull back a bit to the
speech and chat based interfaces that
might feed off of our moods or our
gestures or other kinds of things that
we might be able to use in these other
spaces and this is the piece that's the
startup that I'm working on at the
moment okay so it's insurance
I know insurance is something most of
you probably don't think about if you
think about insurance it usually means
something bad happened you or someone in
your family had a house up in Napa that
would be a time you'd be thinking about
insurance you had a car accident your
roommate left the faucet on all night
these are times that insurance comes up
but the truth is that actually if you
look at what's going on particularly for
vulnerable populations and for
developing world issues insurance is an
economic driver that pushes a lot of the
kind of positive development that we
would like to see so a very simple one
of these is why do we not have
self-driving cars how many of you have a
car that has the capability to drive by
itself right now okay how many even have
cars you're not and I'm not in a car
world okay if I ask that same question
in Southern California half the room
would
their hands right the technology is here
the reason we don't have self-driving
cars is because we don't know who the
heck should insure them we don't know if
it should be the manufacturer if it
should be the occupant if it should be
the owner because the owner and the
occupant might be two different people
and so on same thing when you go to
developing countries and other kinds of
underrepresented areas development
happens when people can reduce their
risk so when I can buy a house and
insure it there's not nearly as much
risk when I can buy a car and insure it
and so on but at the same time it's a
super old industry it's a massive mess
and what we know is that current sales
and service models are super expensive
and risk pools the sort of original
model of insurance is basically five of
us in the room get together we each
their twenty bucks in a bucket it's one
of us trips on a stone couple days later
and you get the hundred bucks out of the
out of the bucket right that's what a
risk pool does but it's they're large
they're diffused they're not
comprehensible and they're really
coarse-grained and hard to administer so
if you don't believe me two years ago
60% of insurance Commission revenue was
compensation for the producing agent
that's ridiculous more than half of the
money is going to insurance salespeople
it's not going to pay for your revenues
that's not risk pooling anymore that's a
financial instrument and the
coarse-grained issue
so here's Palo Alto here's the old flat
boundaries your flood maps were recently
redrawn homeowners in the room you're
probably aware of this because your
flood insurance changed based on these
boundaries blue regions mean there's
about a 1% chance per year that's what
people call a 100-year floodplain it's a
really terrible way to describe things
because 1% chance means like 35% chance
over the life of your mortgage that's a
more comprehensible way to think about
that orange is a 500 year flood so
that's 2.2 percent chance in any given
year but this is basically how FEMA does
this if your house is here you buy
insurance and you buy it a certain rate
if your house is here you buy insurance
and you buy it at a more expensive rate
if your house is here you don't have to
buy insurance
this is stupid this is now have floods
work right
this is how funds work right so what we
saw is this hurricane season and if you
don't have family on the East Coast you
may or may not have been paying that
much attention that this year's
hurricane season but what we see is that
because it's all built on these risk
pools in these very coarse-grained
models you have development in places
that there probably shouldn't be you
have people who have the least ability
to understand the statistics and the
flood bottles living in the places where
they shouldn't be developing and we hit
the poorest and most vulnerable among us
and they're typically underinsured and
they're paying too much for it so it's a
combination of issues so then how do we
fix that well the problem is insurance
is confusing and personalized quality
service traditionally has required human
agents so that gets us back to the 60%
of your of what you're paying for your
insurance is going to that person who's
helping you buy it so if we replace this
with better data science to help us
target these niche products we
understand those data models so that we
can make it understandable
we create new platforms that allow us to
do things like show you a visualization
of what a floods gonna actually look
like at your house instead of just a map
that says you're in or you're out of a
flood boundary help people pay online
have chatbots to do automated sales and
service so we can drive down costs and
you get a virtuous cycle because if you
drive down cost you get more people to
enter the pool you're more people to
enter the pool you drive down costs and
round and round and round it goes so
this is what we're trying to do right
now to make we're staying out of health
house is a mess but we're trying to make
property and casualty better for the
people who are most vulnerable and most
in need of this kind of service all
right so across three very different
sets of issues who've got blind user
interfaces kids and adults with autism
and then insurance for underrepresented
groups what we see is machine
intelligence and new platforms provide
us new ways of creating these user
experiences that hopefully are lower in
cost and higher in quality this is
always the big question
and then my big goal the thing I care
the most about is that brought we have
broader engagement broader engagement in
our design processes broader engagement
in using our computational systems in
having social lives and having social
experiences and then entering and
remaining in the economic market whether
it's because you're now able to get a
job or whether it's because you're now
able to buy a house or purchase
insurance or whatever so thank you to
all of you for listening to all of this
to all of these people for paying for
all of this come to UCI it's really warm
and sunny and near the beach and our
applications for our masters in the HDI
program will be available very soon PhD
applications are already available and
we're hiring two HDI faculty this year
and we're particularly want technical
faculty so all you awesome computer
scientists who do HDI work please come
and there's all my info and I finished
right on time yay and those who need to
go to class escape I want deaf
they might judge you I can't say
anything about your faculty what shape
the shape display in particular that's
its own thing but lots of tangibles are
used by the blind community so for
example you'll see tangible school
artifacts so for example you're trying
to teach kids about sine cosine and so
on
you actually have pieces of wood or 3d
printed increasingly pieces that will
show that one of the big challenges with
those things is again they're sort of
static they've to get printed all of
those kinds of things so there are
people who are working on can we
dynamically create tangible displays in
classrooms and other places and so you
do see that largely it's an issue of
expense and accessibility and we're all
have everybody's super excited about 3d
printers you talk to like Jen man coffin
ami Hertz and a bunch of other people
who are doing really cool stuff except
for the big problem is wet anybody knew
3d printers themselves are not
accessible so you can print the thing
that you want to print to help you do
the thing that you need so you always
have to have someone helping you so this
is their sort of big problem so what
you'll see instead is like teachers and
Families investing in these kinds of
technologies for their kids but once you
get out and you're independent you sort
of got your stuff going you get pretty
good with your screen reader or whatever
and you sort of just tolerate the
badness which is not a good way to go
about life but there you have it so we
need to do better we really need to do
better and the gap is growing right so
every time you see a really cool web
interface that's super dynamic and
responsive
you've widened the gap and that's a real
problem right so when it was like DAF
you could actually like Dawson the
screen reader that's fairly comparable
experience actually but we're widening
the gap and we need to do better and the
basic legal requirements for
accessibility is just not good enough
not too familiar with this but I always
wondering it's for pitch because pitch
sounds like a really hard concept to
show and think about it and try to fix
if there's some sort of visualization
perhaps that can help you it's like if
you could visualize in real time in a
way you could try to fix it yeah we
tried I would really welcome anyone else
who wants to try better visualization
people than I am I need to get like Jeff
here unless there's something you know
we tried a bunch of different things and
basically it was all cognitively too
complex in the moment which is how we
settled on just flashing flat because
when you're trying to most people can't
interpret graphs there's I forget what
the percentages but there's some
ridiculous percentage of graph
illiteracy in America and so you've got
to now teach people to interpret the
graph or whatever the other
visualization is and we tried a bunch
and have a conversation and it's already
hard enough to have a conversation if
you think about you know when you're
getting alerts you're having a
conversation while driving and you're
trying to pay attention to that or
whatever the same kind of thing right so
we don't want to distract people too
much visualizations and other kinds of
things like that is something that
people do in a reflective model so not I
in the moment model and that's something
behavioral therapists are quite good at
and I will tell you even there if you
look across the literature we're not
making good progress on pitch even in a
reflective model so we kind of knew it
was unlikely that we'd make good
progress but we wanted to see the other
thing I'll tell you is our dosages are
small so if you think in sort of a
medical model of pharmacological dosages
most of our studies because we're
working with people who's really hard
for them to get into the lab and whether
it's because you're blind or you have
autism or you know you're low-income or
whatever it's really hard to give in the
lab it's really hard for us to get to
you we typically don't have them using
these systems ever really extended
periods of time one of the things I
think my lab especially needs to be
better at but I think all of us need to
be better at is upping upping that
exposure and seeing if maybe we are
actually making a difference but we just
can't measure it because we don't have
high dosages
yeah you mentioned that neurotypical
folks and folks will have a difficult
time like figuring out is there some
consistency in terms like pitch or other
factors between folks of different
cultures such that like someone couldn't
learn yeah I don't have a cultural stuff
I can tell you gender though women
almost always up talk I just did it
right and so this is really interesting
right because there's lots of studies of
whether if you can teach yourself as a
woman to not up talk if you actually
come across as stronger and more
confident and all these other kinds of
things I also have a student who is
trans and so grew up being socialized to
talk like a woman and he up talks when
he talks and so in person you don't
notice it we overcompensate with the
visual channel but on the phone people
always think he's a woman and despite
the fact that he's on the house
structure he's transitioned a long time
ago but it's the up talk that basically
signals woman so there's one for you and
I can't I've actually tried to train
myself not to talk because of that and
I'm terrible I mean you can hear me
doing it all the time now I'm all
self-conscious about it but so that's
something to look at I'm sure there are
things culturally about when we end a
sentence how long do you wait before you
talk again all of those kinds of things
I have a one of my best friend's her
husband's an attorney and I will say
this is hilarious one he can't ever get
a word in when he's around professors
but when we're around all the attorneys
it's a very different thing and that's
because attorneys are strongly
socialized to wait an appropriate amount
of time before speaking after someone
else speaks because if you cut someone
off in court it's really a problem you
might go to jail for it
and we're as faculty we just all over
each other right and so there's there
are certainly if you think of those as
like micro cultures there are certainly
cultural indicators of when someone's
done talking yeah
question offline matter since it's past
time excellent
you